and we're going to continue our coverage
of the war in Ukraine now Russia and
China are going to conduct military
drills in partnership with South Africa
now this joint exercise is going to last
we understand around 10 days however the
South African government says the
country is not abandoning its neutral
position on the conflict we're joining
to discuss this our security and defense
analyst Professor Michael Clarke and so
how does this work South Africa taking
part in military drills with China and
Russia get its remaining neutral
eyebrows will be raised for sure yes and
they've really chosen the right time to
do it there they are in the United
Nations we expect later on today
sticking with their neutrality not
committing themselves to condemning
Russia and on the very day that is the
anniversary of the first anniversary of
the war they're about to conduct
military drills with Chinese and Russian
ships this is a ship that everyone's
interested in this is the Admiral
gorshkov the Russian ship the Russian
frigate which is the flagship of their
frigate Force carries the Zircon missile
the Hypersonic missile which President
Putin was only boasting about again this
morning they say the Russians say they
won't fire the Zircon missile in these
tests but we'll see about that
interestingly though they're not just
meeting up at Sea this is the the
goshkov in Richards Bay yesterday so it
went alongside and when ships go
alongside they put their Flags out the
big Zed on the uh on the tower and it's
a diplomatic thing officials go on board
and pay their respects so you know this
has all the diplomacy this is this is
the Ukraine war from Russia's point of
view it's performing a diplomatic
Mission so it it's it's raised some
eyebrows in South Africa as to why with
our neutral position are we hosting or
we can joining in on this exactly on the
anniversary when everyone's thinking
about the war it's a very assertive
statement of non-alignment yeah creating
a very Tangled diplomatic web there I
will keep an eye on that in the meantime
let's talk about ammunition a Ukraine
saying they need more
um you know the Western allies saying
that they need to supply more but
there's difficulties all over the place
with this in terms of stock stocks of it
and creating more yeah yes I mean the
ammunition I really need is artillery
shells both sides are getting through
prodigious amounts of artillery the
ukrainians are firing off about 5000
shells a day most days the Russians more
than twice that and the artillery they
normally use is that the 152 millimeter
is the old Soviet artillery that's what
the Russians use the ukraines had a lot
of that but they've moved to Nato
standard artillery the 155 is slightly
bigger and we've chosen this photograph
of the 155s here because it shows it can
get very old and it still works I mean
some of this stuff was produced in the
1980s but if it's properly stored it
still works if it's not properly stored
there'll be a lot of Duds but the whole
point about artillery is it's very basic
stuff and you need lots of it millions
and millions of shells are stored around
the world ukrainians need them but they
also need more accurate artillery and
these can be made more accurate as an
Excalibur version of it which has got a
guidance system is more accurate what
the ukraines are really asking for is J
takums which is a joint tactical missile
and these are missiles that can be fired
from multiple launch rocket systems
which they have got but it's the rain
range of these things accuracy and range
they've got 300 kilometers range very
accurate if they really want to get at
the Russia's Russia's Logistics as they
were doing before Christmas Russia's
pulled all the logistics back so now the
ukrainians need another missile to get
to those systems that are further behind
the front line this is what they want
president zielinski has mentioned it
specifically they need this as much as
they need f-16s and they're hoping for
it and then there's some improvisations
there's a wonderful thing called the
ground launched small diameter Bond and
it's a lot of bombs that Boeing produced
had a lot of spares a lot of missiles
that um SAR produced they put them
together it's cheap it's accurate it
hasn't been used yet but the Americans
have said yes we're putting this onto
the battlefield it hasn't been tested
anywhere else and the ukrainians will
get that in a few months time and again
it can be launched from a multiple
launch rocket system accuracy is what
they want